all right everyone how's it going this
is the volgen on the SCP were gonna be
studying today is scp-1689 object class
SIF special containment procedures
scp-1689 is currently under restricted
access an area for medium sized artifact
storage compartment scp-1689 is to be
stored tight shut with its mouth facing
upwards at all times access is limited
to level 3 personnel with the exception
of sight cooking stuff exploratory
access to scp-1689
a requires approval from level 4
personnel all expeditions must be
documented with a complete manifest of
equipment and staff to enter enzymatic
combine 13 has been developed to eat an
exploration of scp-1689 - a proposals to
establish a mobile site n scp-1689 a are
currently under review description
scp-1689 is a burlap bag of potatoes and
it's stable state scp-1689 weighs 40 to
50 kilograms and contains approximately
200 common agricultural potatoes tubers
of solanum tuberosum scp-1689 is made of
brine roughly woven jute I say I'm not
right JIT yet I know the interior of
scp-1689 is vastly larger than its
exterior and it's designated scp-1689 a
scp-1689 a has a large extra dimensional
space of undetermined volume measured to
be at least 10,000 meters cute but
believed to be much greater completely
filled with potatoes exploration of
scp-1689 a is largely incomplete due to
the high degree of obstruction for more
information please see addendum to
exploration log 1689
i when portions of scp-1689 day are
empty nearby potatoes experience an
abnormal form of Bruce characterized by
trimmer like bulges emerging and
eventually splitting into fully sized
and dependent potatoes the rate of
growth is roughly exponential with a
doubling period of approximately two
yars this effect also applies to normal
potatoes introduced to scp-1689 as well
as similar edible tubers or routes such
as yams and sweet potatoes although not
have been fine to occur with an scp-1689
naturally addendum 1689 - one scp-1689
was recovered from cry Silvo a small
village of approximately 200 people in
northern Siberia a Russian official
reported on the second of June 23 not
crevo sue had made no outside contact
and for decades and had no surrounding
farmland the reports were confiscated
and investigated by the foundation at
which point it was discovered that the
village had been using scp-1689 as its
sole food source for well over a century
as a result the villagers were suffering
from extreme calcium and iron
deficiencies no one in the village was
able to recall hi they had common to
possession of scp-1689 only that had had
been there since before the reds and
that it was a gift for working hard
scp-1689 was subsequently transported to
areas its current location
addendum 1689 - 2
currently only one fully equipped
expedition into scp-1689 a has taken
place authorized personnel may view the
mission log of captain Cameron Wales
and here is the expedition look opening
statement exploratory mission 1689 - I
was scheduled for the 8th of August 2015
with an exploration team of four led by
captain Cameron Wales the team was
informed of their upcoming assignment on
the second for more information see
document mission 1689 - I equipment
manifest mission log captain Wales day -
6 they told me today I was going to be
leading Frederick Carlin and Zander into
sack of potatoes
ok apparently it's bigger on the inside
or it's a pocket dimension more it's a
portal or something is somewhere full of
potatoes at this point nothing surprises
me oh and this is supposed to be an
official log so I'm supposed to call
them agents Morell Oz loose and Peterson
no in checks days so I [ __ ] won't
mission log captain Wales day minus 1
they gave us the rest of our gear and
gun is ready for tomorrow
the plan is to be there by noon LOB's
produced this really cool liquid force
DS some kind of acid or enzyme that
dissolves the potatoes into a starchy
paste it mostly drains away but then
some of it sort of hardens to make this
nice tunnel ceiling it's actually scary
how fast it works and we've had to wear
skin protection too it doesn't get on us
with spray nozzles we can carve our way
straight into potatoes mission log
captain Wales day 0 it was pleasant to
find that they had already cleared out a
small room on the other side of scp-1689
made of plywood
it was certainly weird crawling back
into a bag and coming out in a totally
different room but then again nothing
surprises me we actually didn't see any
potatoes right away then we opened up
the excavation door
yep all the potatoes potatoes above in
front on blue we decided to cut a
roughly 2 by 2 meter tunnel
straightforward compasses they'll work
here but there isn't a very good chance
of getting lost because we can always
find our way back from the radio signal
mission log captain whales day 1
excavating slow work we can clear about
30 meters and are not signs glacial but
it's a hundred and twenty cubic meters
of potato and that's a kilometer in two
days if we make good effort and it isn't
that hard to have a spray and two of us
shovel away the goop every 100 meters or
so we put up some support beams whoever
invented this enzyme is a genius mission
log captain whales they - god I hit the
order this stuff I actually like the
smell of potatoes because of the enzyme
this place smells like vomit sick of it
already
[ __ ] mission log captain whales day 5 I
accidentally spilled some enzyme on the
grind today it turns out we're only a
meter off this concrete floor come-ons
really surprised this is the first thing
other than potatoes they find cool we
decided to just start going on the floor
it's not too inconvenient and it's nice
to have solid food mission log captain
whales day it did you know that the word
spud comes from digging with a speed to
make the hole that you plant them in
Karlin did and she made sure we all dead
- and then she repeated the word spud to
herself all day why we were excavating
mission log captain wells day 9 this is
hardly even age and work why don't they
have the class the endless
mission log captain whales day 11
tomorrow we're on our own it's becoming
too inefficient to resupply us every few
days so commands providing us with two
months of MREs and tanks have more than
enough enzyme to last that long if we
haven't find anything after that they
say then the mission will be abundant
obviously we'll still have radio contact
mission log captain whales date well
it's nice being alone with the team at
night it's almost like camping
yeah compa and a weird cavern made of
spuds mission log captain whales day 16
I did the blue something really
interesting happened we find a wall
today it was made of the same material
as the floor the base floor about the
starch stuff concrete it runs at an
angle 20 degrees they are tunnels
perpendicular come on told us to follow
it now that it's not like there's
anything else interesting going on
mission log captain whales day/night
team so concrete floor and concrete
walls today Frederic got thinkin and
sure enough concrete seen it this whole
time it's been about 3 meters above us
which means that the whole time we've
been inside of a building a huge
building if we can map it out we
probably find the exit and discover
we're in the world this potato hell is
mission log captain whales
day 28 Zander says it poo tattoo what
the [ __ ] how have I not heard him say
that until night it's been four weeks
surrounded by potatoes and he hasn't
said the word until night he's the first
person I've met who actually says it
like that mission log captain whales day
36 it's been longer since we started
following the wall down from the wall to
the start Xander thinks it isn't going
anywhere
but Fredrik wanted to press on come on
deferred to me and well
I don't want the last month to have been
pointless we'll go for another three
kilometers at least mentioned look
captain wells day 38 today we decided to
blow a [ __ ] hole in the wall Carla
had her charges in her pack God knows
why so why not the wall isn't going
anywhere we all stood clear and blasted
took a long time to clear out the mashed
potatoes away but maybe sure enough
created a three meter hole yes what was
on the other side potatoes mission log
captain miles day 39
we started excavating through the hole
we made and turns out it's actually
different outside it's definitely
outside the grind is dirt on extremely
dead grass that means this thing isn't
anywhere on earth
I guess the building was some kind of
gigantic warehouse we've been hearing
these sort of faint rumbles ever since
we blew the charges down under start to
go wily about it but as far as I can
tell
long hoppin mission log captain Wales
day 43 hi hi up to these potatoes go if
we're outside then there's no vertical
clearance so does it go all the way up
to the atmosphere is the whole universe
filled with potatoes
it's so weird think of where I'd side it
doesn't feel any different from being
inside the building it's like we're
underground well I guess we are it's
just the grind is made of potatoes mush
and look captain wells
day 44 we find an actual tree a dead one
surrounded by potatoes but a tree rooted
in the ground
nonetheless we had to be careful about
it because the enzyme chews it up but we
managed to fully uncover it its branches
were sort of weird splitting at these
perfect 30 degree angles but overall
looked pretty normal
the lab had me collect a bark sample it
totally made the outside fact real what
is this place
mission log captain whales day 48 Xander
was worried about the rumbles we've been
here so he turned back to look turns
ight about a hundred meters of our
tunnels Kiev dead
come on didn't know either they said
they'd start taking outside from the
other side and that it was my choice if
I wanted to keep excavating Frederick
and Carlin want to continue so continue
we do less thing to Xander complain I
didn't sign up for this [ __ ] yeah no
[ __ ] foundation didn't exactly know you
were going into the realm of taters when
they recruited you it's not the kind of
thing you put in the fine print just in
case mission log captain Wales day 51 we
keep finding more weird [ __ ]
frederik uncovered this twisted bicycle
and got super psyched about it I neither
had to be humans here before because of
the buildin but it didn't really occur
to me until I saw the bicycle Jesus
mission log captain Wales day 55 [ __ ]
I'm an awful captain there was another
big rumbles today a huge given we nearly
got crushed but somehow we all managed
to take safe refuge under the tree
branches this time we lost contact with
command we can still detect some faint
radio transmission but it's too staticky
for correspondents obviously I made the
call to turn back but we have no idea
how bad it is it could take weeks to get
a [ __ ] should it turn back mission log
captain Wales day 62 Frederick told us
today we should have brought an Irishman
I told him that he was an [ __ ] it was
chuckling all day long what an absolute
prick mission log captain Wales day 65
we run out of food rations today sounder
freaked out and started saying we were
gonna starve until I told him he was a
[ __ ] idiot mission log captain Wales
day 67 I should have brought a guard
down space kit Carlin actually had
cooking equipment in her pack God knows
why so we can prepare the potatoes a
couple of different ways but it's still
potatoes my taste buds are gonna shut
down
this is gonna take forever mission log
captain whales day 68 it's too hard to
clear at the original tolls we made
it'll be quicker just to cut straight to
the bag enemies tomorrow I'll tell my
team just to start carving our new
tunnel mission log captain whales day 69
[ __ ] we're on our to ven's I'm today
sure I noticed this applied to emblem
but it doesn't really work to ration it
so we just kept using it like normal and
I were right okay so the good news is
that we were inside the building what
had happened that means we can shovel
our way out as there is a ceiling it's
five meters from top to bottom
I can't imagine we could make a tunnel
and a narrower than a meter and a half
that's gonna be slow but we should get
there
the real digging problem is space where
are we gonna dump the potatoes the best
we can do is about five meters behind us
so we have a little bubble of space that
we just sort of move through the
building this is gonna take a long time
but honestly not sure what we'll run out
of first food is covered and they've
actually got enough water in them the
oxygen is starting to get still though I
don't know how much is able to fit in
the cracks between the potatoes I don't
even know what to do from morale I've
told everybody that command is probably
digging from the other side and it's
gonna find us but they're all depressed
this was supposed to be a 65 day mission
max Fredrick made a joke about the word
tuber I don't remember exactly what it
was stupid anyways mission log captain
Wales day 70 maybe it's because we're
just melting them but there's something
none of us in the risk before the
potatoes are really ugly looking they've
got these bulges which sort of wiggled
and grow slowly absolutely disgusting
and there are only men mission log
captain Wales day 71 I hate the smell of
potatoes
I'd Huff the phone with back just for
the smell [ __ ] mission log captain Wales
day 72
it's [ __ ] smaller our bubble of space
is smaller and it's because of more
[ __ ] potatoes our area wasn't
precisely dimensioned or anything but
Colin was the first dimension at when he
woke up and then suddenly it's obvious
to everyone the whole area is shrunk a
good 10 cubic meters what the [ __ ]
mission log captain Wales day 73 I was
paying attention today
there was ugly bulges they actually get
baked fast and when they get to be the
size of a potato they split off that's
where all the potatoes are coming from
our area got even smaller today mission
log captain Wales day 74 we're running
out of space and time there's barely
enough for him to work anymore or
knocking elbows and shoulders while we
shovel [ __ ] taters [ __ ] spuds
[ __ ] the arms [ __ ] tubers [ __ ]
roots
I swear they'll kill me while I'm
sleeping and I'll have a potato [ __ ]
stuff down the throat mission log
captain Wales day 75 all day long
Xander's whining shut the [ __ ] up I hit
the dark too we all hate the dark on the
yellow lumps with the brown potatoes and
the tasteless food we all hit it ok ok
it's not like I can yell at the team I
keep them all going I'm the captain
Captain Wales potato commander I keep it
together and vent it all in these
[ __ ] logs mission log captain Wales
day 76 I can't breathe account [ __ ]
breathe and there's no room the shovel
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
mission log captain Wales they 78 I feel
like and breathing inside someone else's
lungs
he's already exhaled so there's nothing
but carbon dioxide no one can even speak
while we're working
we're dead within a week death by
potatoes
concluding statement on the 3rd of
November 20 mission captain whales and
agents oz loss Merle and Peterson
connected with secondary excavation team
although they were suffering from oxygen
deficiency and then a deteriorated
mental state all team members fully
recovered within three weeks
captain whales declined to write a post
mission summary all right then that's
finished it's done thanks very much for
listening everybody and have a good
Patty's Day goodbye I would like to give
a special thank you to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Allen Setzer premier
Romanov Tiber ball and dr. mortis thank
you all so much for your support is
greatly appreciated if you've been like
a special thank you at the end of each
of my videos on smaller cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
you